Joe Biden has a big problem some
Democrats aren't buying his Malarkey on
garage gate president's lawyers found
five more classified documents in his
Delaware house up to the White House
said the search was complete that's in
addition to the ones Joe said were
secure in his garage right next to his
prized Corvette Dems including Adam
Schiff are having a hard time defending
Biden because it looks like the White
House tried to cover this up
I'm glad that there is a special
prosecutor that's been appointed to him
classified documents are to be taken
seriously no one is above the law so um
I'm glad to see the justice department
doing its work well it's certainly
embarrassing right I still would like to
see Congress do its own assessment of uh
and receive an assessment from the
intelligence community of whether there
was an exposure to others of these
documents whether it was harm to
National Security
you know things are bad when you lose
Adam's shift even the media thinks this
torpedo is the notion that Biden is Mr
competence
it's very very big not legally but
politically it's a very very big deal I
don't think sitting there hunkering down
now
you're just acting like it's not out
there is a good stride they're just
gonna have they're going to get cream
doing it what happened here with these
classified documents really erodes and
undermines not just the momentum but the
brand of that the Democrats had been
building of being the not only the
competent party but the decent honest
Party by stumbling and bumbling around
by not getting their timeline right
Amateur hour is over all right and
Republicans are demanding the visitor
logs for Biden's house where Hunter
lived but the White House claims they
don't exist this is not stopping the
grand old party from wanting more
answers
we wonder if the Secret Service had
records now that's our next question
because he still had Secret Service
protection and you would assume that the
Secret Service would vet people that
would be allowed on the premise of the
dwelling for the president United States
remember the FBI when they raided
Mar-A-Lago they also took the security
cameras to look at security footage did
they do the same with Joe Biden all
right judge this feels a little too tidy
to me how swiftly The Tide is turning
against Joe it's like a high school
where they decide the popular kid is no
longer popular don't you get that
feeling like when Adam's Schiff turns
against you Warnock you know what what's
interesting about this is there's a part
of me that wants to believe that a lot
of this is being promoted by the Dems
because they don't want Donald Trump to
run for excuse it they don't want him to
run either but they don't want Joe Biden
to run for president so here's the issue
Greg that is driving me crazy on
November 2nd president's lawyers say
they find documents classified documents
in a closet at the Penn Biden Center
first of all why were the lawyers there
we don't even know why we want to know
whether or not did it say classified on
the outside did they open it up you know
and then once they did that they say the
next day it went to National Archives in
the November 4th doj November 9th the
doj says they're going to do an
assessment and I get I get because you
know they're corrupt they want to hide
this information from the American
public so they didn't say anything
before the midterms but they didn't say
anything until January the 9th they
could have leaked this during Christmas
week after Christmas week New Year's Eve
this could have all come out my question
is what were they doing why does Kareem
Jean-Pierre get out on January 10th and
say we're all transparent we we have
completed I assume it's all been
completed two days later we found out
there are more documents so they not
only don't have their story straight but
that tells me that they were doing
something during those two months during
those two months I can guarantee you in
that house where Joe Biden said he was
where he was living and Hunter said he
was paying 49 000 a month rent which to
me is money laundering to his father Joe
Joe says he only made nineteen thousand
dollars a month on that house that
Hunter gave him fifty thousand dollars a
month to rent so there's all kinds of
questions that you've got going on here
and nobody's answering them we're
supposed to just say oh it's not as bad
as Trump it's worse at least Trump was a
president these are all Obama arid
documents and I gotta say one more thing
Andrew McCabe of all people to talk
about this this guy gets thrown out of
the FBI for leaking documents he comes
around and he says you know what we
really we really should we should not
give the Republicans anything and we
should should let them do whatever they
want to do but don't cooperate and at
the end of the day it's a huge gift to
Trump that's all ah really all right
Dana I get the feeling that like uh
Biden was kind of like the fake ID that
got the Democrats into the bar by
democrats I mean Kamala Harris they
don't need him anymore well so that this
is their way of pushing them out no I do
think now they might be stuck with him
because his approval rating is going up
a little bit more they they realize that
they that a bloody primary on their side
would be pretty bad Americans usually
re-elect their president's very unusual
not to give them a second term and so I
think the Biden people until this
happened were thinking this will be a
walk in the park this does make it more
difficult but I don't see any Democrat
coming out and actually challenging them
it is good for the Republicans remember
Biden said uh we're going to have that
we're going to be the return to normal
we're going to be able to return to
everything's competent everything's fine
no one ever has to think about us no one
has to worry about us and that is
certainly turning out not to be true on
this story there are challenging the
Afghanistan withdrawal debacle in terms
of a Communications failure this is so
interesting that they continue to
extend the bad news cycle by having a
drip drip drip out there Joe Scarborough
mentioned something he said the timeline
keeps changing something that drives the
media crazy is if the timeline changes
like but wait you said this and now this
when you're looking at these dates like
that doesn't make sense why wouldn't you
have said it but you knew on the 18th
and then and then the press secretary is
like well yeah she can't answer any of
those questions in a way that makes a
lot of sense that's why I don't keep a
timeline it's better not to keep a
timeline it's better not to keep
timeline I think that this will continue
to go forward I I think that the Dems
are going to learn the hard way that's
just saying yeah but Trump was worse is
not going to cut it right this time
around that's true you know Joy I really
want to say the walls are closing in but
I know everybody
appropriating CNN
the walls are closed the walls are
closing in Joey you know they've cut him
off at his knees here
um to use the cliche listen there are
two play here for me as an American
citizen sitting here watching this play
out the first is fairness and
accountability uh investigate Trump for
what had happened investigate Biden for
what had happened they both should be
held accountable for violating protocols
that I would be ruined over as a young
marine and I I love president Trump as a
president I voted for him twice that's
true as a republican do I feel better
about documents that were in a safe
inside of a secured compound than I do
behind Biden's Corvette of course I do
but if both are violations of the same
rule investigate them and put it out
there I don't think there's a lot of
jail time on the table or something like
that but if I want to talk about the
second issue that is a partisan really
is important to me it's this fact that
my buddy Luke that lives at my house
about half the time and loves to uh
partake in in green cigarettes pointed
out to me he looks at me one day in my
gym in the basement and goes you know
they're they do everything they accuse
Republicans doing and he says he doesn't
align but it's true I mean they call us
racist while they're pushing CRT and
this idea of front of the line Equity
they call us warhawks while they're
droning American citizens abroad and
funding a war against Russia they call
us insurrectionists while they're
burning City Hall oh and by the way not
only are they doing that they're
propping up Stacy Abrams the OG election
denier they do all these things that
they accuse Republicans of there's a lot
better at communicating it usually on
the front end like Hey we're gonna go do
this in the back room so let's pretend
like uh we're not doing it and and
accuse them of it at the end of the day
this is I know you are but what am I and
I don't think they're going to get away
with it well here's the thing Geraldo
it's like I it's one of those things
that costs across the blood-brain
barrier it's now the Democrats are
actually coming out and saying things
this is no longer feels that partisan
well first of all I want Joey to invite
me to his basement for the green
cigarettes I think that he owes it how's
it to me
all right
along with your buddy then
um listen I still think this is Eric
Holder and Fast and Furious this is
Hillary Clinton and Benghazi it's a big
big boom and then it all goes away and
at the end of it the people who are the
prime protagonists have that egg on
their face I think this is all about a
bunch of nothing I I really do believe
that they they there were documents in
the garage I don't think anyone has made
the case that they were stolen or that
they were given to spies or that they've
been imperiled or impeached the uh the
National Security of the United States
of America I think that it is all about
partisan politics all about gotcha they
went after Trump they embarrassed Trump
now we're going to go after buy we're
going to get him they raided Trump now
we'll say why aren't you raiding Biden
uh they'll use it in the in the sense
that as a as a political bludgeon
they're all about nothing isn't that
wrong how is that wrong but we're
starting at that wrong right that's why
I'm not up let's say why I'm not a
politician nor am I politically correct
I I cannot imagine what life is like if
this is what you do all day is pursue
these meaningless empty irrelevant
scandals only because the other party
did it it is partisanship pure and
simple and I I you know and when I see
Joe Scarborough and the other Democrats
chickening out and saying Oh The Amateur
hour and uh oh maybe we are bad it
reminds me so much of Russia Russia you
are a lawyer I am this is against the
law pure and sympathy
you are not supposed to take classified
top secret documents and put them
anywhere I submit you would have to
arrest everybody
former presidents senator people are in
jail right now for that you know what a
way to stop it is to start arresting I
know you're really proud of the time you
spent downrange with men and women in
unified I certainly and I want to know
how you go to sleep and not reconciling
what you just said about that knowing
that some of those men and women would
have their lives ruined over doing
exactly what those two men did first of
all I would defend any any service
person accused of this I would defend
with my my dying breath I I think that
is ridiculous and I want us I want to
see any case I've heard uh references
any case where someone really went to
jail because of a negligent handling of
oh my God
negligent handling not intentionally
then the Russian submarine to his
parents and Associates was that his name
I don't remember his name but I know
that the woman I talked about last week
about in the hotel in Indonesia yeah it
wasn't intentional she's in jail we got
to move on I wanna Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now